you want to be on my team huh let's see
what you got
pixar has another hit on their hands
with luca and just like
every other pixar film it's chocked full
of hidden details
whether it be keeping their traditions
of the pizza planet truck alive
calling back previous disney classics or
even hinting at what's to come from the
studio
pixar never fails to keep audiences on
the hunt for references
their italian sea monster tale luca has
plenty of hidden references
so hop on your vespa and let's start
searching
there it is that's how we're gonna see
the world one of pixar's biggest
trademarks of their films stems from an
inside joke between the animation
studio's staff
the number a113 this number has appeared
as a license plate
graffiti and has even made itself part
of the plot in various pixar films
room a113 this is actually a callback to
a classroom at cal arts where many of
pixar's top animators got their start
the number can be seen in the final
scene of the film where alberto hands
luca a train ticket
so he can travel off to the city to go
to school with julia
if your eyes were getting a bit misty
during this scene you likely missed that
luca's ticket number is a113
you can go to school i can
if the diver suit that both luca and
alberto wore during several scenes of
the movie looked more familiar to you
that's because you've likely seen it
before in another aquatic-themed pixar
movie
finding nemo the diver's helmet has the
exact
same design as the one where jacques the
shrimp resides in dr sherman's fish tank
it's fine i'm not human oh
thank goodness another pixar staple is
the luxo ball
the signature ball doesn't always appear
in its original form
as it has shown up in the form of a
shield a merit badge and a steering
wheel
during the film's climactic race scene
there's a blink and you'll miss it shot
of the yellow and blue striped ball in
its original form
lying on the rooftops of porto rosso wow
it's fast alberto's lighthouse bedroom
has plenty of hidden goodies for fans to
look for with one of them being a
callback to pixar's beloved 2008 sci-fi
film
wall-e the boot which wally used to
carry the plant
over the course of the film can be seen
lying underneath alberto's hammock
pretty cool right yeah luca also drops
some secret details to some more recent
pixar films
which we see in the scene where luca and
alberto are swimming to the shore of
porto rosso
one of the boats they swim past has the
name elena printed on it
this small detail is a reference to
abuelita elena
what did he say to you he was just
showing me his guitar
shame on you the pizza planet truck has
appeared in all but one of pixar's films
and is a call back to their seminal
movie
toy story the crew had to get creative
with making the vehicle
fit in with the film setting of 1950s
italy
classic human town pretty cool right the
animation team decided to remodel the
truck into a piago ape which makes its
appearance during the porteroso cup
sequence
isn't it great wall-e's boot wasn't the
only pixar throwback hidden in alberto's
room
if you look closely you'll notice a hat
residing near alberto's hammock which
looks
quite similar to the hat that carl
fredrickson wore during several scenes
in the pixar classic
up hi mr frederickson the hat wasn't the
only detail that harkens back to up
if you look closely during the scenes
taking place outside of the town
restaurant
you'll find a poster advertising a soda
drink and if you examine it even further
you'll notice that one of the bottle
caps on the poster
shares a striking resemblance to the
grape soda bottle cap that ellie gave
carl in the beginning of up
we're in a club now donald duck is one
of the mouse house's most famous
and treasured characters in this scene
taking place in julia's bedroom
a plush toy resembling the classic
donald duck design sits by the foot of
the bed in one of the film's
easier to catch references one of the
two other secret details hidden in
julia's bedroom
is a copy of the original pinocchio book
titled le avencho
di pinocchio this isn't just a reference
to the disney animated classic
it's also a direct allusion to the
book's italian author carlo colotti
which ties directly into the film's
italian riviera theme
the second of two pinocchio cameos takes
place during a dream sequence
where luca envisions him and julia
flying over porteroso before the camera
pans down to reveal pinocchio waltzing
through the italian streets alongside
the lame fox
and the blind cat this also could be
tied to the fact that
in their respective films both luca and
pinocchio dream of being a real boy
i'm a real boy the train sequence had
several
other secret features including the
number 04608
on the front of the train that luca and
julia depart on
that number isn't just any old random
number it's actually the zip code of
pixar's animated studio
come on roberto the train's gonna leave
pixar
sure does love their numerical
references and they took advantage of
the opportunities presented by the
film's finale
in yet another fun detail you can see
the number
1200 pa by the train doors which
actually refers to the studio's street
address
1200 park avenue in the streets of
porteroso you'll also be able to find
posters
advertising many films stemming from
classic italian cinema
but one of the posters is a callback to
one of disney's most famous
aquatic-themed movies
twenty thousand leagues under the sea
which followed a team of deep-sea
explorers on the search for
you guessed it sea monsters watch out
luca
everyone roca pretends to believe in sea
monsters
an album cover with the name nicolo
pietra can be found in julia's room
while casual audiences might not think
twice about the name hardcore pixar fans
might catch that this is a reference to
pixar animator and voice-over artist
nick pitera who initially got his start
making pixar themed music videos on
youtube and eventually went on to work
for the studio
pretty awesome pretty cool he even
provided his voice for the triple dent
gum jingle from inside out
one of pixar's traditions is to have the
directors of their films voice a
character in their own film
brad bird voiced edna mode in the
incredibles while pete doctor supplied
his vocals to kevin in
up just to name a few luca's director
enrico casarosa provided his voice to
the unnamed mustache man wearing a cap
who can be found sitting at a table in
some of the film's town square sequences
casarosa also included allusions to his
first pixar short film
la luna julia's father massimo closely
resembles the fatherly figure in la luna
and both films have plot lines that deal
with a child's curiosity about the stars
to top that off the main child from la
luna makes an appearance as a drawing in
the end credits
alberto i'm coming for you another
allusion to a pixar short film appears
in a climactic moment in the race
sequence where alberto rushes to luca
holding a blue
umbrella to protect his true identity
the pairing of alberto's soul blue
umbrella amongst an
ocean of less colorful umbrellas appears
to be a visual nod to the 2013 short
film
the blue umbrella which features the
eponymous item amongst a swarm of grey
umbrellas
what's that it's just the greatest thing
that humans ever made
the vespa hidden mickeys have become a
trademark of disney's
lucca has one of its own albeit its
origins are a bit different
when animating the dream sequence
following luca and alberto riding a
vespa
casarosa and his crew noticed that one
of the cloud formations resembled a
hidden mickey
thus they decided to keep the hidden
mickey clouds in the film
i am marco visconti five-time winner of
the porto rosso cup
a potential ratatouille reference can be
seen during aircollar visconti's
entrance as air collate and his lackeys
sit outside of a restaurant you might
catch the restaurant's name
gustosa this is most likely a reference
to the famous chef gusto from
ratatouille
who owned the restaurant at the heart of
the story in ratatouille
you might think pixar's luca is just
another hit animated film but a look
behind the curtain reveals that it's
not just a movie about two teen sea
monsters it's
so much more it's a motion picture that
shows us
years of historical italian legends and
personal experiences from the director
himself
that all led to the true meaning behind
luca
ready to find out what that meaning is
luca is yet another historical moment
for disney and pixar
it's their first film ever to solely
focus on italian culture and heritage
as you can imagine that means a lot of
what we see transpire to luca and
alberto as well as the setting has a
real-life basis
sure porto rosso isn't a real italian
town however
it's a near replica of the italian
fishing towns located in the italian
riviera
as for the sea monsters they exist too
at least in the legends of the italian
people
everyone puerto rosa pretends to believe
in sea monsters
when talking about the inspiration
behind the sea monsters director enrico
casorosa
said there's a big history of sea
dragons for example
one is in san frutozo which has the
famous abbey
it's a beautiful place that we
definitely took a lot of reference from
a place that is known for a dragon that
lives there along with the sea dragons
there were stories of friendly octopuses
and feisty krakens that even had
references in the film
kind of sounds interesting when it came
to designing the sea monsters they
pulled out old italian sea maps and took
reference of their illustrations
however they did have to tone down those
illustrations a little when they saw it
become overpowering in the film
enrico said in the beginning we were
drawing them really fantastical
we were fascinated by all these fins and
all this weird and kind of
decorative elements on them in the
c-maps but it was like
no they're attracting too much attention
to themselves things like the fins on
the fish and the variety between them
all came from those old historical items
according to production designer daniela
strzlava they wanted to make sure they
kept the inspiration from the maps but
also
be sure they were able to modify them in
order to fit each sea monster's
personality or home
the filmmakers even made sure that their
underwater scenes were in line with the
aquatic life in the mediterranean waters
and more specifically
ligurian sea isn't it great
plenty of research and personal
experience went into the making of the
film and luca as a character in fact
luca and alberto are loosely based on a
friendship enrico had while growing up
in italy
he credits his past bff for helping him
come out of his shell and get him where
he is today
his family wasn't very present he
couldn't do whatever he wanted
it was the perfect friendship to get me
out of my comfort zone and help me grow
up
what does that mean no idea go find out
for me will ya
the location was also chosen based on
enrico's childhood the director would
visit the italian riviera during the
summer months and his fond memories of
the towns were the reason for the
setting of lucca
but of course enrico couldn't rely on
solely his own memories to create a
movie on italian culture
who wants to watch me eat a big sandwich
although he was raised there he spent
the majority of his adult life in
america
that being said he put together a team
of art designers and sent them on a
mission to italy where they were tasked
with getting to know the culture
food and art in the country eriksen
thinks it's so important to get the
feeling of the place
the light and the details it has so much
history
the goal visually of creating luca was
to be able to transport people to this
beautiful place that you would love to
visit for real but
that you can visit through luca that's
how we're gonna see the world
[Music]
overall the goal of luca was to portray
the epic bonds of friendship
enrico wanted to make sure that the
movie's main symbolism of the importance
of friendship was at the forefront and
not sacrificed for added drama
they even cut certain scenes to make
sure they kept it in line with the
vision
we had much more of a quest and we had a
huge kraken transformation at the end a
big monster finish
we realized that wasn't the story we
wanted to tell
all in all he was going for a stand by
me in italy vibe
luca represented the confusing and
challenging times we all experience when
we're 13. the frustration of not
identifying with your true self or
unsure how to express who you want to be
to others
luca disguising himself was actually a
metaphor for that situation
and another extension of enrico's
personal experience
your life is so much cooler than mine
those years where you feel
odd in your own body and you don't fit
in for many different reasons
so something felt right talking about
that age with the setting
of a changeling someone actually hiding
his true self naturally because he has
to
the contrast between the murky ocean
waters and wide and
never-ending human lands also helped
showcase the cramped feeling luca was
experiencing as a sea monster
you just sit on it and it takes you
anywhere you want to go then they were
able to tie in the iconic italian vespa
to represent the freedom luca had as a
human
is freedom the ending of pixar's sea
monster fable luca won over the hearts
of audiences
around the world and even made them
weepy
what's interesting is that the film
almost took a different route in its
third act and would have played up the
humans vs sea monster feud that looms
over the film
initially the climax would have centered
around alberto transforming into a giant
kraken with luka ultimately having to
stand up against the humans for his
misunderstood friend
the luca team eventually decided to
lower the stakes and give the film
a more simple resolution which certainly
worked in the film's favor
they are the winners
which luca actor recorded most of the
film from their mom's closet
we see the final product but behind the
scenes recording remotely
during a pandemic looks very very
different than normal
this was actually the first time some of
these actors had ever done voice work
today we're checking out the performers
behind the voices that brought us disney
pixar's
luca i know your problem you got a bruno
in your head
a bruno jacob trombley is only 14 years
old
but already a total pro in the film
world
he's done roles in live action movies
like room and wonder
however voice work is a very different
experience and discipline
for trombley it wasn't too much of an
issue anyway since
he has years of experience doing it he's
been the voice of pete for the past few
years in
pete and the cat and of course he will
also be voicing flounder in the upcoming
live-action remake of the little mermaid
his animated voice really brings this
hilarious moment to life
seeing emma berman performing behind the
scenes makes it so hard to believe that
she's still pretty new to the business
this is actually her first major project
are you in town for the race
the while the trio may just be meeting
it feels like they're already at the
beginning of a great adventure and
friendship together
emma berman's sweetness comes through on
the screen and behind the scenes
which is extra impressive considering
she's not acting opposite anyone
jack dylan grazer has done plenty of
movies and tv shows already
i've been doing this forever but it's
still early days for grazer when it
comes to voice over performance
it's it's it's been so much fun it's
really hard it really has so for him
it was a big adjustment since he
couldn't actually look at the people he
was acting opposite
however he really got into it and as we
can see
was definitely able to get his point
across luca
it's simple just don't listen to stupid
bruno this pep talk
works fortunately it wasn't as
drastic for tremblay himself as it
happened behind the scenes
but he managed to portray the panic
extremely well
he's dead i killed him the worry that
he'd lost his best friend
comes through perfectly in his voice
here this kind of acting should be
helpful when he's taking on flounder who
goes through plenty of panic of his own
alberto communicating the fact that he's
a sea monster
could definitely be tricky but somehow
newcomer grazer does a spot on job
it's fine i'm not human what's even more
impressive about this performance
is that it was done out of his mom's
closet very very
very far from this quaint italian town
however grazer had actually just been in
italy only two months before he
discovered he'd gotten the part filming
another project
so luckily everything in his life felt
pretty in sync and he could feel those
italian vibes
wait it's called phantom tail he'll get
used to it
watching berman behind the scenes is so
exciting because she's so animated while
she's performing
we can see how it emanates what her
character does on screen perfectly
julia is an optimistic girl but even she
has her doubts about the abilities of
these sea monsters
and understandably so you can't swim
you can barely ride a bike saturn
disaster
we wouldn't be a fan of disastrous
either how alberto learned to walk so
well
we're not entirely sure but he seems
pretty well versed when it comes to it
luca does have a great and enthusiastic
teacher
even though his instructions might not
be the most helpful sometimes
walking is just like swimming but with
no fins or
tail and also there's no water the
chemistry between alberto and luca is
really special
which is extra impressive since the
actors haven't actually met in person
that's right they developed this
beautiful on-screen friendship and all
without ever actually speaking face to
face
it was like oh wow emma berman makes for
a
very good trainer maybe even better than
alberto
there was no hesitancy in getting them
into shape the boys are definitely being
well prepared by her as she's
clearly thought of everything can you
dodge obstacles
what if an old lady crosses your path we
would just
love to see berman and her co-stars
performing the scene live as well
learning how to ride a bike is a pretty
amazing feeling for anyone
but especially for a sea monster who
let's remember
also just learned how to walk trombley's
enthusiasm
radiates behind the scenes julia said
look up
and then all of a sudden i was writing
it we can see that he and luca are very
similarly animated in their performance
the town will cheer our names erkola's
life will be
ruined once julia has her mind set on
something
there is no turning back we can feel
just how excited not only
julia is but berman the actress herself
it was definitely really really good the
enthusiasm about working with her new
friends and feeling re-inspired
really comes through in this scene they
definitely sound like winners that's why
we gotta win
one of the sweetest moments in the whole
movie is definitely when luca describes
the dreams of his adventures with
alberto around the world
every day me and alberto are gonna ride
someplace new
it's a touching and tender moment that
translates beautifully to the screen
trombley's presence comes through behind
the mic and we can hear
every single sweet note and every night
we'll sleep under the fish julia is one
of the
most organized and determined kids that
we've ever seen
i actually relate to her in some ways
considering her positivity and how well
she motivates the team
it seems like their chances are pretty
good
we have one week to train bronte
they won the enthusiasm award for sure
we love seeing burman's physicality
behind the mic she embodies the
character of julia perfectly
too much my mom says sometimes i'm too
much no way
not for me jim gaffigan is usually a
stand-up comedian
so it makes sense why his performance is
so strong
and his comedic timing so on point all
right young man
you're not fooling anyone his sneak
attack on this unexpecting italian child
brings a hilarious moment to the movie
one that gaffigan portrays perfectly
it's
time for us to go home his energy behind
the mic
really amps the scene up this moment
under the fish
or stars depending on if you're a human
or a sea monster
is a pretty magical moment no matter how
you look at it
that's saturn my favorite berman's
performance is genuine and full of
sweetness
we can really understand how luca would
become so excited by the world and
all of its wonders seeing it through
julia's eyes
this is how machines fly see and they're
big towns called city
so cool right when she's on land luca's
mom daniella does not hold back
even her husband lorenzo is a bit
nervous by her boldness
gaffigan's hesitant performance is very
obvious behind the mic as well
honey no i
i don't it's amazing that his chemistry
with maya rudolph was so strong
even though they didn't get to act with
each other directly
walking is just like swimming but
without fins or a tail
and also there's no water how many times
did you catch moments in lucca that were
eerily similar to disney's the little
mermaid
step aside ariel there's a new sea
cedaland resident in town
and his name is luca ariel and luca go
on similar journeys as do their parents
from very familiar images to the same
lines
we're covering 20 times luca copied the
little mermaid look at her
on legs considering both the little
mermaid and luca take place under the
sea
it makes sense that schools of fish end
up being prominently featured in both
in the 1989 film the fish are present
for songs and swimming through the sea
in lucca the schools of fish swim
through the sea often
following luca when he isn't busy
exploring life above the sea that is
come on underwater treasure collecting
is
all the rage in underwater disney world
luca's fascination with the discovery of
human artifacts
and his collecting of them mimics just
what disney princess ariel did
what's more alberto's hideaway with all
the human stuff he's collected over
time reminds us very much of ariel's
underwater treasure trove
ariel what are you like how could you
what is all this
ariel and luca have shared some similar
views
we're talking about the fascination with
looking up and watching the bottom of
the boats in the ocean
while both are very nervous knowing they
do need to be careful when it comes to
humans
neither can help but just look where do
boats come from
the stories of human monsters on land
above are the primary reason that king
triton and luca's parents give such
intense warnings to their children
the people on land are a threat so it's
a fair point in both cases
the curious fish gets caught both luca
and ariel are curious about life above
and who can blame them
they're both fascinated with it and
really want to move from sea to land
ariel took action to follow prince eric
while luca's main motivation was the
idea
of riding a vespa once they're there
both end up being pretty big fans
the adventures both of them end up going
on are pretty magical
you know he's getting married getting
legs for the first time is bound to be
confusing
for ariel it only takes a couple of
tries and then somehow she's waltzing
with a prince
luca doesn't have the best teacher in
alberto so it takes a bit of time
and some confusing instructions to get
to the point that
he's actually able to run both
characters have to go through learning
how to do this
pretty basic action well enough to pass
off as real humans
and they become experts very quickly
you're in luck i basically invented it
in luca alberto appeared to be the
expert of all things human
he says he knows how to use all the
objects what they're called
and makes some pretty misinformed claims
about the way the world works
really yeah and the big fish protects
them sound familiar
scuttle from the little mermaid claims
to be the expert as well
with his dinglehoppers and thingamabobs
what
what is it it's a tingle hopper
dreaming of life on land can take a long
time
so long that both our leads were caught
missing from their posts
remember when ariel is missing for her
musical debut concert
the same thing happened to luca when his
mom caught him missing from his
shepherding post luca did at least think
ahead and place this stone statue that
sort of resembles him in his place while
he was off adventuring with alberto
okay everyone this is uh
smooka ariel and luca are passionate and
rebellious
souls they just want to go where their
hearts take them
it makes sense that both of them have
strict parents
both king triton and daniella make
really strong points to their children
about not going anywhere near the
surface
and i am never never to hear of you
going to the surface again
no matter what but in the end of course
both
luca and ariel disobey their parents
orders anyway
we do not talk think discuss contemplate
or go
anywhere near the surface among the
humans the rumors of monsters below
are plentiful in the little mermaid the
boat crews speak
directly of king triton and the wild
amount of power he has
thought every good sailor knew about him
in lucca
there are rumors of sightings and even
rewards put out for finding the sea
monsters
as if there's something to be afraid of
the pressure to find and hunt down the
sea monsters is
far more intense the divide between the
humans and sea people than in the little
mermaid
we can almost hear the song le poisson
from the little mermaid as we see the
very familiar actions performed by
massimo chopping off the fish heads in
the kitchen
we've seen this before in prince eric's
kitchen where the chef was making a
seafood feast for the prince and ariel
sebastian lucca and alberto all go
through quite a fight when they see how
the people on land
feel about their fellow kind luca's
first scares in the town square when he
sees the images and of course
statues of sea monsters being attacked
by humans
he and alberto both get a big shock when
this board with photos of fish
all over it appears remember poor
sebastian's encounter with the very
similar board of photos
while alberto and luca aren't as
vulnerable as sebastian at that moment
all of them look equally terrified
ariel doesn't really know how to use a
fork since she's
gotten most of her how to be human
lessons from the not-so-well-informed
scuttle
however she does think she knows how to
use it and unfortunately
shows off her believed to be skills to
prince eric during their dinner
when served a plate of pasta with a fork
luke and alberto have no idea what it
could be for but
soon enough they end up learning how to
use forks really well
they definitely had better luck than
ariel the first time around
hey at the beginning of the little
mermaid
we see a giant boat with fishermen
catching fish aplenty
except of course for the one that
escaped fishing played a key role in
luca as well since
of course it was their first job helping
julia's dad on the boat
that's where they also happened to prove
they'd be extra helpful with their
insider knowledge of life underwater
your friends don't know fish in the
little mermaid we have workers at the
palace hanging the laundry and gabbing
away about the new woman the princes met
we do get another laundry line on a
string in luca
except instead of putting clothes on it
luca's mom daniella is taking them down
to use the clothing for herself and
lorenzo
i'll just get this washed for you
we do sympathize with the parents of
these wild spirited souls
both have to go through the worry of
their children being missing
king triton has a crew of underwater
dwellers to help him out in the search
for his daughter
while daniella and lorenzo take matters
into their own hands and make the
journey to land themselves so they can
find their son and bring him home
or so they think that's what the plan is
wow
it's fast scuttle the seagull is the
first one we see using the telescope in
the little mermaid
of course his knowledge is limited and
the instrument doesn't help him out so
much
we see a fascination with the telescope
come up again in lucca when julia uses
it to show him the details of what the
sky really looks like
and not to mention proving to him that
stars
aren't fish mermaid
both king triton and luca's mom daniella
have almost the exact same line
was i too hard on him wondering about
whether or not they were too hard on
their children
while they were strict it's all just
because they both care
so much for the well-being of their kids
do you think i was too hard on her
ariel luca and alberto all go through
their identities being dramatically
revealed
and it's not a fun experience for any of
them initially
ariel is discovered on the boat when she
misses getting her kiss before the
sunset
talk about bad timing alberto reveals
himself to julia and then is caught by
arcole who is quick to attack
finally near the end of the puerto roso
cup race we have luka revealing himself
in front of the whole town
after alberto has come back to help him
they are
the winners in the end of course both
luca
and ariel get their happy endings with
the blessing and help of their parents
their dreams to live their lives on land
come true
then i guess there's just one problem
left
luca and the little mermaid almost had
one other thing in common
alberto's character almost transformed
into a giant kraken
which we think might have looked a bit
like ursula's transformation from human
to evil myrwich
what was your favorite similarity
between the two sealand movies